ce samedi lors de la manifestation
contre le kazakh cenal organisée à paris
le journaliste de lci paul larrouturou a
été violemment pris à partie les
manifestants l'accusant de marché pour
le gouvernement pour nos riches d'homère
vous véhiculez la voilà bien pensants ça
on devrait vous péter la gueule vous ne
dites rien dénoncé aujourd'hui combien
vous touchiez devrait pas vraiment
si de tels comportements restent encore
rares la défiance envers les
journalistes elles progressent de façon
inquiétante d'après un sondage de l'ifop
55% des français ne font plus confiance
aux médias et 18% éprouve de la colère
vis-à-vis des journalistes si la plupart
des médias français se considèrent comme
des contre pouvoirs essentiels à la
démocratie force est de constater que
certains ont relayé de fausses
informations peut il faut acheter des
masques en formation surtout pas c'est
totalement inutile totalement inutile
comprenez vous la méfiance de certains
français envers les médias
français envers les médias on a quatre
oui et un non en seulement présenté par
malek délégués qui va donc prendre la
parole en premier pour ouvrir et là
évidemment c'est tu n'as faire un petit
peu délicate on parle de violence dans
les manifestations on parle d'une partie
de la france qui se désolidarise
complètement de ces politiques de ces
médias et c'est donc mailhac explique
nous pourquoi toi tu ne comprends pas
tout ça vous allez me vider ce tag est
parce que mon nom est un peu ah oui
aussi je m'explique le jeu peut capter
je peux cafter quand même on prépare
tous les missions à main et moi sur
cette fiche j'ai les positions de tout
le monde donc anthony sophie et
charlotte était censée répondre oui mais
malek et jean-michel était censée
répondre je crois pas cela c'est la
preuve entre ce camp de cohérence à ceux
qui n'en ont pas c'est pas grave
le fait qu'on s'interroge sur les médias
moi je trouve ça sent fait en démocratie
et ça moi ça me dérange pas par contre
moi ce qui me dérange c'est cette petite
idée la petite musique qui dit qu'il ya
une doxa dominante dans les médias je
suis désolé sur ce plateau même dans
d'autres émissions on voit fabrice di
vizio on va le professeur out tombale de
toc le docteur délépine on va plein de
gens qui ne sont pas dans cette doxa de
woods si ici même on peut c'est d'être
des chaînes info si on voit des
personnalités qui sont pas dans cette
doxa dominante même si j'aime pas ce
terme florian philippot notamment etc et
consorts bon moi ce qui me dérange
mondiaux qui sera d'ailleurs ce soir
dans tpm paix je vois j'ai vu ça il sera
là tout à l'heure un mois ce qui m'amène
à dire non c'est toutes ces scènes en
fait que j'ai peur qu'on en vienne en
fait à les banaliser cette scène là avec
paul larrouturou on a vu il ya quelques
mois un journaliste de bfm tv igor
satirique a fini par fuir
aujourd'hui les reporters sur le terrain
sont accompagnés d'agents de sécu en
fait faut à un moment faut se réveiller
tout va bien ils ne font que faire leur
métier couvrir un événement à l'instant
t et est en réalité et même s'ils
n'étaient pas d'accord feront ce faux
pas sur la gueule parce que
les images qu'on a vu en début en début
de match évidemment personne ne les
cautionne mais en revanche cette
méfiance que peut avoir une certaine
partie de la population envers les
médias envers les gouvernements avec
toutes les incohérences qu'il ya eu 2
sur une crise sanitaire ça on peut le
comprendre c'est vrai mais si agathe jeu
vous allez regarder un média vous allez
regarder une chaîne info par exemple il
ya quelque chose qui vous plaît pas il
ya un truc hyper cool c'est une
télécommande a bien sûr ses magnifiques
chine assure à la fois regarder autre
chose
c'est que ce soit sembla d'accord même
d'une scène dans un mexique et une
méfiance exprimé un désaccord ça bien
sûr oui voilà et ça moi ça me dérange
pas mais que en fait on veuille se
[ __ ] sur la gueule tous parce qu'on
n'est pas d'accord mais ça me gêne comme
l'âge sont obligés de le dire aussi il
ya eu un meeting d'un candidat à la
présidentielle il ya peu ou en fait des
journalistes ont été en danger c'est
qu'il faut voilà de leur intégrité
physique était nous on était mise en
cause donc bon voila moi c'est ce qui
m'amène à dire non finalement j'ai remis
oui non moi je comprends tout à fait la
méfiance des médias je suis le seul
journaliste autour de la table je crois
à part que tout journaliste assistante
animatrice savent rester dans la neige
mac c'est vrai que j'ai fait était grand
reporter quand j'étais panne et c'est ça
ouais
c'est pas une tare grand reporter de
guerre et journaliste de métier oui oui
mais je trouve que le métier a tellement
changé que vois je comprends la méfiance
des gens parce que de demander à mon
époque voilà qu'il certes ya une
vingtaine sais pas si loin que ça regain
une dizaine ou une quinzaine m vingtaine
d'années quand on publie l'information
il fallait la vérifier plusieurs fois et
si on faisait une connerie dans un
journal japonais chiharu à la fin de ma
vie journalistique quand on fait jean
grenet ont été sanctionnés a été puni
alors qu'aujourd'hui on est sanctionné
si on sort pas là faut le premier même
si la ffo épouse dont il faut mieux
sortir l'info son premier que être en
retard sur une info donc ça va ça
apporte des dérives et des débordements
qui sont complètement indigne de ce
métier là surtout que maintenant tout le
monde se considère comme journaliste et
il suffit d'avoir un stade g pour se
positionner comme journaliste balancer
des infos sur twitter etc et
journalistes c'est un vrai métier et je
comprends qu'aujourd'hui il ya tellement
de choses qui font des choses dites
qu'ils sont fausses et qui sont effacées
deux heures après par une contre par une
correction
une information qui fait que franchement
je comprends qu'une défiant atterrit
alors évidemment quand on cautionne pas
ce qui s'est passé et la violence envers
les journalistes moi ya quelque chose
qui m'a gêné sur la séquence
anti-vaccins c'est que j'ai regardé la
première fois ça m'a fait un peu rire
les gens qui s'énerve et un peu et puis
et puis après j'ai regardé encore je me
suis dit oh et garde son calme quand
même et puis ensuite je j'ai vu le
bandeau en bas j'ai vu l'instant paul
soucy vrai mais je le connais en fait
c'est un ancien journaliste du quotidien
on est à côté de ça je me suis dit
l'instant molle en fait ça fait plus
pastille humoristique et je me suis dit
est ce que lui n'est pas allé à les
mettre un peu la sauce tu vois ce que je
veux dire mais alors qu'il n'est pas
allé parce qu'en fait on sort en sort
une image de la manif je sais que j'ai
un fermier et que et que on conseille la
vaccination c'est pas le fermier ou sfr
fait un fermier oui infirmiers
[Applaudissements]
juin michel 2022 toujours aussi lourd on
adore comme ça non mais je vois ce que
tu veux dire anthony mais pour le coup
fauvre l'a pas si voilà là pour le coup
ça peut paraître des quotidiens et un
peu humoristique mais vraiment il fait
un vrai boulot journalistique sur les
amis restons sur le débat qui est les
français face aux philadelphia merci je
t'en prie jean-michel je fais ça en
partie pour toi qui est très très carrée
sur cette émission charlotte alors oui
moi je comprends tout à fait la méfiance
des français envers les médias surtout
que 55% des français c'est plus une
minorité ça devient une majorité et je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs problèmes sous
jacents à ça donc la responsabilité je
pense ça peut être imputée aux médias
mais pas que parce que comme l'a très
bien dit jean-michel maintenant faut que
l'information soit immédiate donc les
journalistes n'ont plus le temps de
vraiment chercher de l'information par
exemple comme on l'a vu avec la sphère
des masques il était écrit ans sur site
de l'om est ce que les masques étaient
efficaces pourtant les médias ont voulu
revendiquer ce que disait le
gouvernement parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps d'aller vérifier et du coup ça
fait en fait ça crée des médias
complices du gouvernement
malgré eux ce qu'ils n'ont pas le temps
de bien faire leur travail parce qu'elle
est passée de masques à l'époque donc
voilà c'est ça c'est vrai mais alors
qu'ils parlent d'aller vérifier sur le
site de l'om est quand même pour voir
que si les masques étaient utiles ce que
le gouvernement veut pour voilà pour ne
pas avoir la responsabilité de ça il
préféré dire forcément que ce n'était
pas utile donc en premier par anonymous
ont quand même très bien meilleur cette
saison à ses yeux ils sont peut-être
même meilleur que meilleur jambon de
janvier pas tout dire